it's great to have back on the program
lee mcintyre who's a research fellow at
the center for philosophy and history of
science at boston university also author
of the book how to talk to a science
denier conversations with flat earthers
climate deniers and others who defy
reason it's great to have you back on
leigh
thank you for having me back so when you
started writing this book
it was before covid but we ended up with
this incredible situation where we are
now uh being held back in fact in our
battle against this pandemic in part
because of exactly the type of science
denial that you write about in the book
and you end up actually including covet
specifically in a chapter
what happened was i got the contract to
write the book just uh in mid-march uh
20 2020 just as covid was
uh lockdowns were happening and of
course i'd planned the book started the
research for it even before that
and i told my editor i wanted to save
the last chapter for kova denial and he
said well you know there is no cover
denial well either way
and and so i watched kova denial be born
in real time
you know after having studied science
denial all these years and thinking
about climate denial and anti-vaxx and
just watching it fulfill exactly the
steps that the other science deniers had
laid out and it was all completely
predictable
so i mean where to even start with this
i guess the the first thing would be
maybe let's start a little bit with the
vaccine issue you know before kovid
you actually had some bipartisanship on
vaccine conspiracy theories you had
groups of people on the left who were
skeptical of vaccines because of their
skepticism of big pharma and you had
people on the right who were skeptical
of some vaccines because of their
skepticism of anything that is
government authorized of the fda etc and
there was a little bit of overlap and
you'd have these measles clusters in
some places that are left-wing and some
places that are right-wing when it comes
to covet and the covet vaccine it seems
to have dramatically shifted to what we
would consider the political right is
that perception true and and why is that
you got it exactly right uh before covid
uh andy vax was
more a bipartisan or i should say
nonpartisan because you know you had
liberals and conservatives um and yet in
some ways what happened with uh kovid is
that the anti-vaxx movement got taken
over or let me put it this way this was
the kind of thing that the anti-vaxxers
were were prepared for and it did get
polarized of course you know trump and
the
republican party are part of why it got
so polarized
and then it has ended up where it is
some science denial is politically
polarized
climate change uh covered um some of it
is not uh but that was one thing that we
also saw which was the anti-vaxx
movement morph into the anti-covid
vaccine movement i'm sure there is still
uh folks who are anti-vaxxers in general
who are uh you know on the on the left
sure but you're correct that it has been
taken over now by the right wing
what line of argument is most effective
thinking not generally now just in terms
of getting people to re-examine
anti-science beliefs but
just to get people vaccinated what are
the lines of argument that you believe
would be most effective or is it really
not about argument and it's just about
requirements
well
you you you frame that just right it's
not about argument
um but it can't just be about mandates
and requirements either okay i think
there has to be something i mean
mandates i think are are part of it
because this kind of denial is is
killing us
um but i think one thing that i
recommend in the book is that we make
some efforts to actually begin to talk
to one another and it may seem that
that's impossible because
uh facts don't matter in this debate you
know how how much debate does there have
to be um the problem is that this like
other forms of science denial it's not
just about doubt it's about distrust
and that wall of distrust has grown
when we don't talk to one another and so
i think the best possible thing we could
do to get people to take the covet
vaccine is to reach out to the people
who already love and trust us and talk
to them
those are sometimes the hardest
conversations
but i think that we have to have to do
it
we have to be respectful we have to be
calm we have to be empathetic
and actually listen to what people's
concerns are there's a hell of a lot of
disinformation out there right now
and if it helps think of
cova deniers or vaccine hesitant however
you want to think of them as victims
they're afraid and they're all of this
disinformation surrounding them they
don't know what to do
so
just to be uh somebody who listens uh
you know to that family member or friend
ask them why they believe this why they
trust this source not that that can
actually work wonders
yeah i mean
what you're saying makes perfect sense
and yet i'm imagining even some of the
conversations i've had with viewers
sometimes who say well listen um
the new one is hundreds of thousands of
people have died from the vaccine okay
so that that's one that on august 24th a
very popular facebook video started
spreading
and you say to some of these folks okay
where did you get that idea well i got
it from this video okay well what data
is the video citing and they'll say just
just look at the submissions to the
veyers system the v-a-e-r-s
system and then you say well but listen
have you visited the website anybody can
submit anything nothing on that system
is verified there's a campaign to submit
false reports to that and then they say
no i i i believe that it's real you've
not proven that the reports are false so
then where do you go with that
i think you went a good way down the
road of where where you go with that
when people insist on proof i think it's
important to point out that that's an
unreasonable standard you don't ask for
that standard for i mean you could but
it's unreasonable to ask for it for
anything else they haven't proven that
aspirin is uh safe you know 100 safe i
mean that's just not how science works
science is about building up
evidence and warrant for your beliefs
but it's not deductive logic it's not
euclidean geometry you can't prove that
that something is safe
and and i think it's also important to
point out to folks that just as you did
about the verse system that it's it's
being gamed they're thinking that these
are good faith reports but you know
anecdotal reports
some of those reports are coming in from
trolls they're coming in from folks who
are trying to get other people to
believe false things
and
of course this isn't going to convince
anybody but it's nonetheless important
to know
that the other day i read in a
politifact that the appointer institute
which is the fact-checking organization
had found that
zero
zero uh uh cases of people dying from
the cove uh vaccines so there was not
one credible case now that doesn't mean
that it couldn't happen it doesn't mean
that it hasn't happened it just means
that there is not evidence that it has
happened
but you know compare that to the
ridiculous numbers
sorry that are being proposed you know
i've heard people say you know that
they're 10 000 or more or a hundred
thousand more where are the why aren't
aren't the media reporting this then why
are you know you only finding it in the
vera system or you know you're hearing a
rumor from your cousin
they're
these would be reported
but they're not and it's yes it's fake
i mean the problem with that of course
is and you know we've we've done a bunch
of interviews on conspiracism and
conspiratorial thinking
um if they find evidence for their uh
conspiracy theory no matter how flaky it
becomes supportive of their conspiracy
theory
if they find an absence of evidence like
the fact that there is not media
reporting it's part of the cover-up and
it becomes evidence of the conspiracy
theory if there is
you know contradictory evidence then
that evidence has been concocted and is
not trustworthy and i just don't know
how we really deal with that on a
wholesale basis your ideas make perfect
sense empathy listening one-on-one it
feels very
sort of retail and i don't know that it
deals with the wholesale problem of the
millions that fall for this stuff
um
you bring up a good point here there are
once you're talking to people who have
fallen for it it's in some sense too
late oh it is okay it's already spread
right right so i mean we should be
talking more about who's behind the
disinformation campaign and how the this
information gets amplified
uh and i can say a little bit more about
that if if you want to yeah please i
mean what but once that's out there in
the world then you know you do have to
talk to the to the deniers and let's
start with that
um
you it's it's
generally a good idea not to get into a
factual debate with them because their
position is not really based on facts in
the first place and right jonathan swift
said you you can't reason somebody out
of something they didn't reason
themselves into in the first place
but notice a couple of the things that
you've mentioned
they have to do with logic they have to
do with evidence they have to do with
the way that people are reasoning on the
basis of evidence and so to point out
you know to a conspiracy theorist
well what could convince you that this
conspiracy theory is wrong then right
because if there's evidence for it you
accept it if there's no evidence you
think that that counts for it too i mean
how how do you know that this is the
case you know so
you know talking and there's in fact
good empirical evidence now there was a
study in the nature human behavior in
2019
which showed that something called
technique rebuttal can work against
science deniers all science deniers
engage in the same form of toxic
reasoning they cherry pick facts they
rely on conspiracy theories they engage
in illogical reasoning they rely on fake
experts and they think science has to be
perfect and once you know that blueprint
you can call them out on it
in a respectful way
but you know you don't have to get into
a
factual debate you know where what often
happens with me is somebody will send me
an email and say well you know here are
20 things that you need to read
immediately
um you know and i
i don't i don't i'm not going to get
into that debate with them because you
know why are they trying to convince me
if they have the evidence they should be
trying to you know convince the cdc the
other scientists now they'd say that's
part of a conspiracy what i always do is
i punt to the idea of well let's talk
about your reasoning let's talk about
how you're you've come to the
conclusions you've come to why do you
trust this person you know why do you
trust this video that you saw etc etc
and the interesting part here is
to a group of conspiracy theorists
raising the issue of trust
that might work for you
right and the the other thing that
sometimes i mean this is when you get a
couple of these conspiracy theorists
together oftentimes their justification
they might end up with the same belief
but with very different justifications
and getting them to realize that they
don't even agree with each other about
what even is the proof like flat earth
is a classic one where the explanations
for why people come to believe it are
often conflict with each other and it
can get pretty interesting when you
actually get them saying well here's how
i came to the conclusion versus how you
did and they conflict very much
and and yet they all ultimately agree
with one another on the conclusion right
because of what they have in common
which is distrust
they have distrust of scientists
distrust to the media distrust of um you
know government
and so
here's the thing that i found in in this
research that i've been doing
if it were just about doubt
then evidence would help because you can
overcome doubt with evidence scientists
do it all the time
but distrust
cannot be overcome with evidence alone
distrust has to be managed by
having the person grow to trust you and
how do you do that you do that through
trying to build a personal relationship
with them through engagement now that is
a very frustrating uncomfortable and
difficult thing to do yeah and most
people would rather walk away than do
that
the reason i wrote the book is to make
it clear to people that if you do that
you're being a denier
because there is scientific evidence
which shows that every day ordinary
citizens like you and me can go out and
talk to science deniers use technique
rebuttal and maybe change their minds so
why aren't we doing more of that now
that's not sufficient you know they're
there again there's a problem of the
creation of disinformation it's
amplification we've got to do something
about both of those things
but what can we do every day just right
where we sit we can talk to people who
disagree with us engage their your
cousin engage your uncle at thanksgiving
talk to them about why
you know what are your reasons for not
getting the covet vaccine we can ask
them we can have a conversation about
that one of the last things i wanted to
talk about there seems to be this meta
problem
where particularly in the trump era
there is now not even i i don't know if
agreement is the right term but there is
a lack of understanding as to what
counts as an empirical claim and what is
just an opinion
and we are very frequently seeing for
example when people are presented with
just the the the empirical reality of
for example whether it was really
trumpists who did the trump riots and
they come back and say listen it i i
just
my that's fine you can believe that my
belief is that it was antifa and they
they think that what these issues are
issues of opinion when they're really
just issues of fact is that a broader
educational problem or how where does
that stem from
the problem this is why we need to take
science denial seriously because it's
not only about covid and about climate
change but it has metastasized now to
reality denial what i'd call post-truth
that stopped the steel the idea that the
january 6 was antifa this is a denialist
campaign it's a classic denialist
campaign that follows the same five
tropes of reasoning about conspiracy
theories etc that i gave you before
right that's why we have to get ahead of
this now you ask exactly the right
question where does this come from
and the answer is
it comes from the folks who are creating
the disinformation
we've got to stop thinking of science
denial as an accident or a mistake it's
a lie
someone is intentionally creating
disinformation not misinformation but
disinformation now to ask who
uh quite a bit of it is from foreign
intelligence services uh for instance in
russia
uh people may not believe that but it is
out there i didn't break into cia
headquarters to get that information it
was out there in major media in about
march or april it was about a one or two
day story
but um there was a terrific article in
the new york times about a year and a
half ago called putin's long war against
american science there are russian troll
farms that manufacture disinformation
about
health issues
about gmos about about covet about
anti-vaxx because they want to undermine
uh the united states they want us to be
at one another's throats fighting about
what we're fighting about they've done a
great job of it right here's the
interesting next step though
though that disinformation is then
picked up and amplified on social media
and it doesn't take that many people to
do it
there was a story in npr the other day
that the um
65 percent of the
anti-vax propaganda on twitter was due
to 12 people right i mean so
this is why we've got to realize we're
in an information war
and in an information you know as a
country
and in an information war you have to
figure out who's
spreading the propaganda and how it's
being propagated so i think that in the
wall street journal series this week i
think makes a pretty good case that
facebook is not doing a very good job
self-regulating they know how polarizing
their platform is they they understand
that they're helping the spread of
disinformation they're not doing much
about it
the book is of course how to talk to a
science denier conversations with flat
earthers climate deniers and others who
defy reason we've been speaking with the
book's author lee mcintyre lee always
great having you on i appreciate your
time
thank you so much for having me back